pardon is just so likable on every level
and she's so witty too yes she is so
fabulous
a brilliant mind too she's been so uh
prodigious
in everything she's done like the cake
mixes run rose run are now available for
purchase and miss dolly parton and our
friends at dunkin hines were kind enough
to send us this awesome bacon collection
which features southern style dessert
recipes here look at all this i know
that never let us loose in the kitchen
but we have
the coconut cake batter
and actually we say we but it was
natalia our producer who last night
produced these uh cheese
so we're gonna like what decorate we're
gonna decorate uh with the vanilla
frosting i'm assuming this is the she
made the coconut cake she was going to
do the butter one
or the banana one but she said there was
too many ingredients it involved putting
in a and some other ingredients that
made it much more complicated which is
so dolly isn't it she she does not skimp
on the butter apparently there's a lot
of stuff that goes well that's that's
the southern
girl in her i mean i grew up in the
south and we used to my mom would make
biscuits for breakfast every morning and
we called it biscuit soup because by the
time she buttered them they were
floating in the butter and that to this
day i love a lot of butter on any bread
is there any way to eat a biscuit
without a ton of water no there is not
otherwise i think what are you doing
they just passed a law concerning that
as a matter of fact
yeah okay so i'm a big frosting fan okay
do you go a lot of frosting i do i do
and how what are your feelings on
coconut unfortunately i am not a fan of
coconut so i'm making these for our uh
our friends okay so
my method of coconut is the more the
better so oh okay i'm gonna go with a
little trick i learned on coconut
and
instead of sprinkling you you make a
little coconut that makes sense and then
you just
dip
i think that's brilliant actually
voila yeah that that makes a lot of
sense yeah that then you have them
the perfect you and nanny bobby just
have all these like secrets in the
kitchen oh hey
if there's one thing i can do is put
coconut on a cupcake that's about it
there